I think a lot of ladies would like to
know what Sharon Stone is drinking these
days because she looks phenomenal but I
mean 27 years after her breakout role in
Basic Instinct
Sharon still knows how to get people
talking she does I mean that's something
I want to share with you one of the main
questions that I always get asked in an
interview want me to take a lie-detector
test
61 wearing a low-cut sequin mini dress
and the only prop Sara needed was a
chair that she recreated her most iconic
scene I was sitting on a soundstage and
my director said can you hand me your
underpants because we're seeing them in
the scene and you shouldn't have
underpants on but we won't see anything
and I said sure I didn't know that this
moment would change my life it's nice
and I want you to join me in a moment
that changed my life
ready set go do you feel empowered
maybe not let's do it again Sharon's 19
year old son roan was in the audience so
watching his mom win GQ Germany's Woman
of the Year award there was a time when
all I was was a joke wrong wasn't even
born when Sharon made Basic Instinct in
1992 it was a gateway drug you push the
envelope in a way we may have broken the
envelope yes I think we have new
envelopes since then each and every one
of you is gonna have a moment like mine
a moment that changes your life what are
you gonna do with it
[Music]